yeah like you have like that one
documentary you watch that just like
blew your mind oh this is an
embarrassing one when I was a kid the
one that blew my mind was a very taboo
one it was called
was it Zeitgeist the one that was like
looking at religion is a scam 911 wasn't
inside
it's a conspiracy theory yes uh
I think it was called Zeitgeist or
something like that right yeah it was
yeah it's something like that and it was
like it was basically a 4chan video but
they put they put it on like uh like DVD
and I watched it and I was like whoa
this is nuts 911 was done by Bush
yeah I was like whoa they're making
crazy arguments the God's not real yeah
like I was blown away
holy [ __ ] that was like the one like I
guess that wasn't even a documentary it
really was how your friends about it I
did yeah you know guys we didn't
actually like crazy like I legit had
like the same thing happen and I was
like 12 because when you're 12 you think
that like people who make stuff like
movies or film must be correct because
they yeah and it's on DVD because it's
on DVDs it's on movies and I remember I
had this one I told the story the
podcast once but I uh we had to do a
school presentation and I just watched
it was like in front of like a class of
like 20. I just watched a bunch of
things about the moon landing I didn't
believe it right I didn't believe it and
then there's like 911 stuff and you know
the whole like wind wing dings yeah yeah
if you type in like certain things on
wingdings on Microsoft Excel oh my God
it's it's proven that 911 was was uh it
was like uh fake obviously all [ __ ]
so I went to school I did this
presentation and what I expect to happen
was my teacher would be like you're a
[ __ ] idiot what the [ __ ] wrong with
you my teacher was like oh [ __ ]
dude the wing dings thing is
at the time I thought damn big brain
dude and then like days later my friend
was like dude you're a [ __ ] idiot
what did you watch I don't know some
random Youtube and I realized I just did
like a [ __ ] conspiracy theorist pitch
to like a bunch of 12 year olds and
you're almost and you almost convinced
your t-shirts I'm pretty sure my
teachers to this day thinks that moon
landing his face
like from a 12 year old kid I'm like if
I was able to convince my like 20
something year old teacher the moon
landings were fake as a 12 year old I
don't think she should have been
teaching to be fair that I feel like at
age 12 or around there like as long as
you say something with absolute
confidence you're most likely to believe
it my dad trolled the [ __ ] out of me
with that kind of stuff when I was
little like oh my God your dad just like
what was it what was what did you
jealousy yeah so I said it on one of the
live shows but like uh my dad uh so our
family used to play like a little like
card games like you know like Solitaire
obviously but like a lot of like other
card game and stuff like that and my mom
was really good at shuffling the cars
like she did like the whole like
flicking the wrist kind of thing and
like pulling it back and stuff bridging
and stuff and I'm just like you know as
like a 10 year old you're just like whoa
that's sick what the [ __ ] yeah and then
my dad one day was just like yeah do you
know why your mom's really good at
shuffling it's because she used to be a
dealer in Vegas
and I believe that [ __ ] until like Age
19.
and and like and I would tell that to my
friends
your mom might be cool but uh my mom
used to be a dealer my Japanese mom my
Japanese
used to be a dealer in Vegas and then I
think it was like 19 or 20 or something
my dad was like son I have to kind of
come clean
um yeah your mom wasn't a dealer in
Vegas I lied to you this entire time and
I asked my mom about and she's like yeah
I've never even been to America
I don't know what your dad's talking
about and so ever since then I'm just
like whenever I hear something or like
whenever someone tells me something in
the utmost confidence immediately my
mind's just like is it really though is
it really the first time I found out the
Lavender Town like copy pastors bro I
thought it was so real the kids
I listened to it oh my oh my god there
was like this whole thing where it's
like if you performs it played it
backwards or slow or something I don't
know it was it was a creepypasta which
was you know Lavender Town in the first
Pokemon game because all the Pokemon
died yeah like which is where like the
the Pokemon graveyard is yeah that theme
song apparently in the Japanese version
they used a certain frequency that only
children
ages could hear and apparently there was
like three or four cases of like
children between the ages of like five
and ten going insane listening to the
Lavender Town Theme from the original
Japanese version and people believe that
[ __ ] dude I believe that I only read it
like lap that [ __ ] up being like yo
Nintendo's got a dark secret bro when
are they gonna come out about the Dark
Side of Nintendo and then you know years
later people realize it's just bull
that's the classic one the Rugrats all
being dead yeah
also I love telling that to people in a
convincing voice being like yeah this is
real yeah this is actually what George
Lucas wanted yeah this is actually what
he wanted they wouldn't let him have it
Disney
was gonna buy it yeah I think my
favorite hoax that has happened recently
was what happened with the Neo automata
Community oh that was a secret little
[ __ ] yep oh my God that was so five
hand on yokotara's like part him just
like playing along with it the thing the
thing about it so if you don't know what
happened basically
um basically there was a video posted on
the near subreddits of this new part of
near automata that had like never been
found before it was an Easter egg
or anything no mini map no nothing
um and it was from a user that
apparently like you know tried to post
this clip in the subreddit uh to find
out how to get out of this area what
this area was yeah and uh and there was
this entire like Odyssey of just this
user posting more and more areas of this
map that had just been uncovered and
this had like the new the near community
on like like he had them on the tip of
their balls you know he he had their
balls
yeah he had a vice grip on the [ __ ]
balls man
um and it was and the thing is it
wouldn't work for any other game yeah
because for any other game you'd be like
oh it's just a model it's just a prank
but yogotaro seems crazy enough to like
forget about something this big or also
yokotara actually made like a statement
being like Oh my God this is an amazing
secret I'm glad somebody finally found
it it was more vague he was more like oh
this is interesting I wonder how that
got yeah
he'd been making like a really like yeah
slides and people like oh [ __ ] it I
should go into the game and try and find
it yeah
unfortunately it was a mod it was a new
mod community that you know had modded
the game even though the game couldn't
be more before that brief moment dude
near stocks just went like oh my God
yeah yeah so it was so big brain yeah I
wasn't even like a big fan of Nair but I
was like like eating up everything that
was like going That's what Nintendo
needs to do like they need to bring back
the Lavender Town thing like like
Satoshi Tajiri just needs to be like
yeah yeah uh yeah I knew one of the kids
that like was awesome it was really
unfortunate and I actually owned the
original coffee in a vault the Nintendo
headquarters somewhere yeah just
bringing back porygons
oh my God Jesus okay I'm trying to think
of like other copy passes like what they
have like back in the day there's none
that were like that reached like the
level like Ben Brown do you have like a
favorite copy pasta from back in the day
it's not really a copy past pretty
faster right yeah yeah Creepypasta not
really I was never huge Creepypasta guy
I like the video essays on it like Ben
Drowned was great like that was super
cool that was good because I feel like
Ben drown was actually just interesting
yeah it was just how they made it it was
just fun it's like it was a good story
yeah so not this isn't a hoax but my
favorite Theory like fan theory around
something is snow piercer being in the
Willy Wonka Universe if you know that
one
piece of the like the train yeah the
Train movie yeah yeah it's a really
conventional you want to explain yeah
I'll do my best it's super deep so a
YouTuber made this very good video that
explains how snow piercer is likely a
sequel direct sequel to Willy Wonka and
the Chocolate Factory yeah and the
conductor like the main guy at the end
have you all seen the movie yeah yeah so
the guy at the end uh that's Charles
that's Charlie Bucket so his argument is
it's set up in the same way that the
Chocolate Factory was you know it's all
self-sustaining food plays a big part
with like the Cockroach bars and [ __ ]
like that yeah and it's set up in like
the class system where you move up just
like in the Chocolate Factory yeah and
he breaks down like all the parallels
between the characters in Snow piercer
and Willy Wonka and then he also
explains how bong Joon ho the director
was a big Charlie in the Chocolate
Factory fan who in an interview at some
point said something about how Willy
Wonka had inspired him to make something
like snow piercer right so he connects
all of these threads that have no reason
to connect well but does a great job of
actually making me believe there's a
chance that this does have some
connection it's really good it's called
snow piercer uh it might be easy to snow
peers there's a sequel to Willy Wonka
okay I'll check it out it's cool it's
really well I have so much admiration
for people who can make fan theories
that work yeah that work like I just
want to imagine like their entire like
bedroom is just like the [ __ ] cork
board was like all the strings attacking
and [ __ ] like that just like trying to
figure out yeah actually I've always
wanted this because you know like the
Zelda Timeline right yeah the Zelda
Cannon timeline so the Intel before
Nintendo released it like there were
like so many [ __ ] fan theories like
you know theorizing about how all the
Zelda the games connect together and it
was only after like it was only like I
think like five ten years ago that the
Nintendo actually make it Cannon but I'm
like there's no way they [ __ ] plan
this right no I swear to God they must
look at these fans make a new game
one of the most like convincing fan
Theory and was like yeah let's go with
that yeah because because like I think
compared to all the fan theories the
only difference was in Zelda Ocarina of
times there are like it diverges into
three timelines it's a little two times
yeah yeah I'm like this is way too
[ __ ] convenient I swear to God in
someone that Nintendo was looking at
these fan theories and like they were
like we can make this a thing we can
definitely make this a problem well they
probably looked at all the fan theories
and was just like all right next game we
need to just completely just [ __ ] up the
time so that they can just start from
scratch make them work even harder yeah
where does this fit in the timeline huh